the epic finale
of "Cupcake Wars".
What should we watch?
Uh, you wanna do a movie?
What time is it?
11:30?
All right.
If we watch a 90 minute movie,
I'd take an Ambien in an hour--
You wanna take a shower.
No, I'm not.
All right, whatever.
You wanna see
what's on demand?
Yeah, what are the free ones?
(announcer)
See it live with Pay-Per-View
from Time Warner Cable.
Catch Reese Witherspoon in
"Squiggle Dumb Dumb".
Jim Carrey in
"Holocaust Downs."
Oh, my God,
can you mute it?
I'm going to kill myself.
I'm trying.
All right, any of these--
Do you like these?
Mmm.
Uh, what's "Lake Placid"?
Uh, "An enormous crocodile--"
No, no, no.
Read more descriptions.
"Kevin Kline is a single father
renovating a secret barn--"
Mm-mm.
"In 1950s Lebanon--"
No.
Ooh, "Pitch Perfect"!
No, no, no.
We're not watching
"Pitch Perfect" again.
You liked it.
No, I dealt with it.
Let's go to
the Showtime movies.
Yeah, no.
Oh, we have that documentary
on whale fracking.
It's like,
the worst kind of fracking.
I think they found a worse
fracking since they made that.
There's no way.
I dunno, we know
we're gonna watch it.
Like we're definitely
watching it.
Right, okay.
So, just-- but tonight doesn't
feel like the right night.
All right, I agree.
We'll definitely
watch it.
We'll do something else.
Yeah, just find something..
What about, uh,
"Amore"?
No, I don't feel
like hearing accents.
I think it's "Amor".
"Amor".
"Spring Breakers".
"Paranormal Sexual Assault".
No.
"The Decapitating".
"The Frightening".
"The Crispening".
What?
"The Worsening".
"The Haunting
of David Finklestein".
There's "Evil Dead".
No.
No, I'm like,
already scared all the time.
I really don't want
to add to that.
Someone told me it's
not actually not that scary.
It's more like just
light raping.
What's the description?
"'Evil Dead.'
Captured in the woods,
"an injured girl is restrained
in a basement.
"Her father sets her
on fire and shoots her dead.
Which is what she deserves."
No. I just want to relax.
All right.
He made a "Twilight"?
Why aren't you using
Page Down?
I'm using Page Down.
Oh.
"The Darker the Berry
The Sweeter the Drank"?
That's true.
You want to start a series?
I never saw "Carnivàle" on HBO.
Ooh, "Cocktail"!
What? What?
"Cocktail".
The movie.
I don't think I've seen that.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Tom Cruise is a struggling
flair bartender.
You never saw "Cocktail"?
Oh my God, it's so good,
it's amazing.
No, that's it,
we're watching it.
Well, no--
We're watching it.
You've already seen it.
Yeah, but I want
to watch you watch it.
Oh, it's so awesome.
We're watching it.
Fine.
We're doing it.
"Cocktail".
You're gonna freak out.
Oh, my God.
(music plays on TV)
I feel like I'm remembering
they don't start
bartending for, like,
10 minutes into the movie.
I'm just going
to fast forward to that.
But just the set-up, like,
he's having a hard time.
Oh my God, this part.
Oh my God.
(man)
You wanna see a cocktail menu?
(man 2)
Uh, no.
I'm not drinking, thanks.
(bell chimes)
Yeah, he caught it.
Okay.
So is that--
Is that kind of the gist of it?
They just do tricks.
Like, so much-- They get into
so many shenanigans.
Oh, we need ice cream.
I'm going to go
get some ice cream.
What--
I'm gonna run out.
If you're going to be gone,
I'll pause it.
No, no, no, don't pause it.
Watch it.
You-- Watch this.
You're gonna... watch it.
(man)
Are these peanuts
for everybody?
(man 2)
Yeah.
(man)
Oh wow, great bar.
♪ When I'm leave
you're gonna long for me ♪
♪ When you longing
for my kiss ♪
♪ You'll long
for more than this ♪
♪ When I leave you'll
long for me ♪